B Bonsoir à v vous.
VoVous allez bien?
- - Ça va bien mais il fait fro.
- - Elle fait -3 à M Moscou.
RaRaphaël, bonsoir.
J'J'ai fait longuement, on troue
imimportant aujourd'hui de faire
lele point sur la crise
ukukrainienne avec Tamara.
OnOn l'a beaucoup fait du pointe
vuvue de poutine. Tentons de
l'l'affaire du point de vue du
prprésident américain. Je commee
avavec Élisabeth. Que peut faire
WaWashington devant cette voloné
feferme de poutine de reconstrue
unun mur de sécurité autour de
lului?
- - On voit la volonté de poutie
dedepuis quelques années déjà,,
dedepuis le sommet de Bucarest
cecette volonté de sécuriser sa
frfrontièrere en utilisant certs
ararguments et certaines posturs
ququi sont surprenantes. C'est n
enenjeu déterminant pour les
prprésidents Biden aujourd'hui.n
reremettre en cause l'ordre
ininternational libébéral qui en
ororbite autour de Washington
depuis 45. Les présidents Biden
n'n'a pas s d'autre option que
d'd'êtrtre fermé et de définir
clclairement les objectifs et de
trtransiger le cas échéant avece
prprésident Poutine mais pas
dodonner l'impression qu'il
héhésite. Or ont laissé, il a dt
quque finalement peut-êtrtre que
pepetite incursion n'était pas e
évévasion. On a vu BLinken dire
quque ce n'est pas ce qui se
papasse. Le problèmeme de Bidena
lélégitimité est érodée. On part
dede la débâclcle afghane et de,
c'c'est certain qu'il a été éro.
LeLes républicains de mêmeme qua
gagauche du parti démocrate...
ilil y a vraiment une escalade i
esest en train de se dérouler ax
poportes de l'Europe. Il va
fafalloir qu'elle agisse.
PoPourquoi? Parce que Pékin sont
dadans les estrades et regarde e
ququi se passe. Si Biden est
fafaible, ce serait peut-êtrtret
unun contrôlele total des crises
ininternationales qui pourraient
lului échapper.
- - Je reviens tout à l l'heurer
lala question de la peut-êtrtrea
grgrande évasion. Effectivemente
quque vous avez dit, beaucoup de
gegens l'ont dit en mêmeme temp.
C'C'est révélateur parce que ily
a a les pays européens qui diset
àà W Washington : écoutez, je ne
fafais qu'ajouter des petits
momorceaux ne va pas tout virerà
l'l'envers. Fermons la parenthè.
QuQu'est-ce que quand je Raphaë?
- - Je me permettrai de rouvrir
cecette parenthèsese. Elle est é
d'd'une perspective américaine.e
quque Monsieur le secrétaire
esessaie de répéter depuis des
jojours, pendant son voyage en
EuEurope c'était qu'il allait y
avavoir une réponse par uni si
MoMonsieur Poutine devait allere
l'l'avant. À quel point est-ce e
l'l'Occident est vraiment inné?
VoVous mentionniez l'Europe. Il
fafaut parler. Il y avait un
sésénateur américain à l la
tétélévision la quelque jour, qi
sese moquait de la Russie en
didisait que ça faisait semble
êêtrtre payé. Je vous soumettrai
quque dans un contexte où les
paparties de pétrole est en tran
dede se diriger vers les 100 $,t
quque c'est à p peu près s le ts
d'd'approvisionnement pétrole en
EuEurope qui vient de la Russie,
MoMonsieur Poutine tient
prprésentement beaucoup de gensn
EuEurope par les bijoux de
fafamille. C'est très s difficie
popour les présidents américains
dede réellement présenter un frt
ununi face à M Moscou présentem.
- - Les craquait dans l'OTAN, iy
a a une modulation Élisabeth, ts
leles pays ne voudraient pas
réréagir de la mêmeme façon en
EuEurope. Raphaël parle du
pépétrole, du gaz aussi que
l'l'Europe importe beaucoup de a
RuRussie. C'est comme si l'OTAN
auaussi allait se redéfinir.
- - Absolument. Les fractures st
imimportantes à l l'intérieur me
dede l'Europe. Selon que vous ês
l'l'Allemagne, vous n'avez pas a
mmêmeme vision de la menace de
RuRussie.
OnOn a l'impression d'êtrtre sua
liligne de front et ça fait
lolongtemps qu'elle sente...
- - pour que ce soit clair, enve
lala Lituanie etet la Lettonie.
- - Dans laquelle la population
rurusse à l l'instar de son coni
dadans l'est de l'Ukraine est
asassez importante aussi. C'est
inintéressant d'avoir les
sisimilitudes, ce qui fait qu'ee
reressentait présent. De mêmemee
papar exemple des états comme la
FiFinlande où il y a des
popositionnements différents eti
onon regarde effectivement du cé
dede l'Allemagne, elle voit
popoutine avec la main sur le
rorobinet de gaz et ça les
ininquiètete de manièrere impor.
DaDans le mêmeme temps, la Fran,
MaMacron est en élection et il
s's'est présenté comme le
prprécédent européiste. Il faut
ququ'il arrive à f fédérer les
EuEuropéens autour d'une
sesensibilité quand mêmeme, d'ue
papassion commune et c'est
vrvraiment un problèmeme. L'OTAt
enen train de se redéfinir maise
ququ'il faut noter, c'est que
ququoique disputée, autant avait
ououvert la porte à l la Russieà
l'l'époque de la chute du mur de
BeBerlin. L'OTAN n'a pas toujojs
étété opposée à l la Russie.
IlIl n'y a pas toujours eu des
dydysfonctions. L'Ukraine était
neneutre en 2014 lorsqu'il s'est
avavancé en Crimée. L'exigence e
neneutralité de l'Ukraine, on
trtrace la ligne rouge que l'on
veveut. Éléments les plus
imimportants : il faut se souver
ququ'en 94 lorsque l'Ukraine red
seses armes nucléaires à l la
RuRussie, la garantie, ce que la
RuRussie n'interviendra pas. La
mémémoire est une faculté
sésélectif.
- - Justement, revenons à L Luc
TaTaine.
SiSi Vladimir Poutine décide de
fafaire un coup d'éclat et
d'd'envahir une partie, la Crime
esest déjà a allée le recherche.
IlIls sont allés, on va
réréexpliquer ce qu'on a dit.
L'L'Ukraine une fois que le
gogouvernement pro-russe a été
chchassé, les ressentis : vous
popouvez faire ça mais pas
ququestion de laisser aller la
CrCrimée. On garde la Crimée et
jujuridiquement, et encore, les
RuRusses ont le contrôlele de la
CrCrimée. Raphaël, c'est l'âgég,
esest-cece que ça mais pas pout,
BiBiden est dans l'obligation de
rérépondre quand mêmeme?
- - Répondndre comment?
QuQui que ce soit sain d'esprit
auaux États-Unis qui souhaitent
prprésentement un conflit armé
avavec la Russie, ce qu'on est n
trtrain d'évoquer à W Washingto,
c'c'est la possibilité, et on se
prprojette, on pense quand mêmee
fifinancer directement par le
bibiais du trésor public américn
unune insurrection antivirus.
C'C'est une option considérée. -
dedelà d de cela, on brandit le
spspectre de sanctions depuis ds
jojours et des semaines. Les
sasanctions, on n'en a imposé
cocombien? Il faut toujours revr
jeje crois cette affaire et la
dydynamique particulièrerement a
peperspective de Moscou. Parce e
d'd'un côtété, vous avez la mene
dede sanctions.
CÇa n'a pas donné grand-chose. a
peperspective d'Vladimir Poutine
dede son régime, l'expansion de
l'l'OTAN dans sa cour arrièrere
paparce que c'est comme cela qul
vovoit les craintes depuis
lolongtemps, ça veut comme une
memenace fondamentale à l la sue
mmêmeme du régime. Qu'est-ce que
vovous pensez qui pèsese le plus
dadans la balance pour Moscou? a
memenace de sanctions
adadditionnelles ou une menace
fofondamentale à l la survie du
rérégime? Pour répondre à v vote
ququestion Patrice, qu'est-ce qe
pepeut vraiment faire Joe Biden?
FrFranchement je suis pas sûrr
ququ'il a de très s bonnes répos
acactuellement.
- - Il y a peut-êtrtre des
éléléments...
ilil y a une forme de populisme
auaux poutines sans sur le
nanationalisme russe parce que a
vava pas très s bien. C'est plua
susurvie des poutine que la sure
dudu régime qui est en jeu d'une
papart. D'autre part les
sasanctions. Ce qui a changé
fofondamentalement et c'est
vrvraiment important c'est
ququ'aujourd'hui les premiers
papartenaires de la réussite dea
chchaînene. Des sanctions qui
afaffecteraient la Russie
totoucheraient deux partenaires:
l'l'Europe qui n'a pas intérêt à
sese confirmer robinet de gaz et
lala Chine n'a vraiment transigé
dede manièrere importante avec a
RuRussie. Poutine et i se
rerencontre et ils vont continur
unun mécanisme financier paralle
popour arriver à c contourner le
mamagnétisme occidental ils sont
mimis en place. On peut tout à
fafait imaginer que cela mèneneà
unune alliance de circonstance
enentre deux ennemis aux deux
adadversaires importants. Ça
chchangerait substantiellement a
dodonne et c'est pour cela qu'il
vava falloir qu'elle trouve un
momoyen d'agir de façon d'une
enentreprise
- - Quand les Russes disent quad
onon a réunifié l'Allemagne,
onon n'en a parlé plus tôt,t, ia
eueu les pourparlers importants
amaméricains et russes et on a t
: : OK. On aurait promis que les
grgraines, les pays de Varsovie,
l'l'OTAN n'irait pas les cherch.
EsEst-ce que cette promesse, c't
clclair pour tout le monde pour
efeffectivement s'été engagée àe
papas inclure des pays comme
l'l'Ukraine?
- - La légende veut que ce soit
unune boulette. C'est un
pepersonnage de l'administration
etet ça a été démenti tout de
susuite mais mêmeme à ç ça qu'on
reregarde du côtété des histori,
mmêmeme d'autres disent que ce
n'n'était papas évident. Ce n'ét
papas clair.
IlIl y a des choses qui se sont
didiscutées de façon étrange.
ToToujours est-il qu'il y a eu n
cecertain nombre de transactions
ququi ont été faites à c ce mom.
C'C'est certain qu'elle est mode
dédémocratique d'ordre libéral
ététait une espècece de bulldozr
ququi a écrasé certains hacker
imimportant qui s'était exercé e
l'l'autre côtété du mur. La pore
ététait ouverte sur la Russie. a
phphilosophie était moins ce que
popoutine raconte aujourd'hui.
- - On a parlé beaucoup de la
CrCrimée. On parle de l'Ukraine.
UnUn épisode des années 90 q qun
ououblie, c'est à d dire la Géoe
enen 2008. Ce qui s'est passé en
202008, ils avaient parlé de
l'l'ancien secrétaire d'État.
BuBush était allé au printemps
202008 desquels autant ajoute la
GéGéorgie quatre mois plus tard,
popoutine envahissait la Géorgi.
- - Contre l'avis des
rerenseignements.
- - Il reste les États-Unis.
IlIl n'y a plus rien qui passe.
CoCommençant ligne les prochains
momois pour Joe Biden?
- - Mal.
PrPrésentement, ce qui lui faite
plplus mal politiquement, ce sot
leles questions de nature
écéconomique. C'est pas évident
popour moi à c ce stade ce qu'il
pepeut vraiment faire.
PaParce que le menton ce qui est
dede la lutte à l l'inflation. s
reregardez les derniers sondages
pupubliés dimanche derniers, on
dedemande aux Américains ce qui
popourrait changer votre
apappréciation du président. Es-
cece que c'est par exemple que n
mamaçon à f faire passer certaie
ceces plans qui sont bloqués coe
énénormes plans de répondre ça?
MoMoins de cas répondent oui. On
leleur demande s'il était capabe
dede faire baisser l'inflation
apaprès s améliorer votre opini?
6060 % disent oui. Il y a des
prproblèmemes sur laquelle il a
l'l'air de ne pas êtrtre
susuffisamment concentré et même
cecelle-ci mettait à t temps plà
papartir de maintenant, ce n'est
papas capable manque
nénécessairement qu'il a du
popouvoir sur les derniers.
- - La hausse des taux d'intérêt
vava avoir un impact sur le
poportefeuille des individus. Ça
vava aussi avoir un impact sur s
momodes de vie et les hypothèqus
etetc. De toute façon c'est une
sisituation qu'il va perdre sur
totous les plans d'autant que
l'l'éléphant dans la piècece est
lilittéralement le parti
rérépublicain qui persiste et qi
a a changé profondément. C'est
l'l'élément important que l'on
cocommençait à v voir aux dernis
élélections quand discuter tous
enensemble. Le changement est
anancré. Ce n'est plus le mêmeme
paparti. Ce parti n'avait plus
àà t transigé. Encore une fois,
ilil n'y a pas de deal.
OnOn les voit. Elle n'est pas
memeilleure négociateur. Enfin
chchangement de style. Il essaie
pepeut-êtrtre d'avoir un point e
vuvue plus populiste.
- - Quand il a inauguré cette
ususine de plus, il y avait des
élélans...
RaRaphaël.
CoComment résumer? Y a une voix
popour s'en sortir? Y a-t-il un
susujet qui va...?
C'C'est terminé. Mais on a faitn
bobon tour d'horizon. Je suis ts
cocontent.
MeMerci d'avoir été là